everyone my name is James I'm a producer
with gearbox software hi my name is Joel
I'm from 2k Australia in case people
haven't seen the news lately 2k
Australia and gearbox software are
collaborating on an all-new Borderlands
title called Borderlands the pre-sequel
now this is a full new standalone
Borderlands title which is coming to
Xbox 360 Playstation 3 and Windows PC in
the fall of this year and where you to
give a run-through of the demo that we
prepared for PAX East earlier this year
so why don't we get stuck into it yeah
all right so right now we're looking at
Athena who is one of the new playable
characters she's a sort of famous NPC
from Borderlands 1 DLC the general Knoxx
DLC right now we're putting our skill
points into the Phalanx tree which
enhances her kinetic aspects which is
this energy shield that Athena has that
allows her to absorb attacks from from
enemies and throw it back at them all
right let's go and get looting over here
we have one of our new loot chests we're
gonna go and open up we're going to see
what we've got inside all right looks
like we have one of our new cryo guns
cryo is a new ice elemental that we've
introduced from the pre-sequel fires ice
bullets that allow you to freeze enemies
and shatter them we also have the laser
gun which is a new gun type so it has
different kind of laser attacks each
manufacturer has their own kind right
now we're looking at the Mallee one
laser gun and we might run into a couple
of different types later on that we can
show off this is the odds kit this is an
o2 kit you need o2 because you're on the
moon's surface of pent-up endorsement
which was to help this and Elpis is just
like Earth's moon in the sense that
there's very thin atmosphere very low
gravity so you need oxygen but there's
not really much on the surface looking
at our other playable character we'll
home you might have seen that there's a
sort of a shimmering bauble over his
head that's his oxygen bubble that
allows him to breathe on the surface the
entire time that you're out there your
oxygen but don't worry we've got plenty
of stuff in place to make sure that you
that you always have opportunities to
get more oh to a case in point we've
just found one of the air geysers you
run on top of one of these things it's
gonna fill up your oxygen this is really
important not just because you need
oxygen to breathe and live but because
we have some new features that we've
added that use oxygen
joël once you tell us them about that
yeah so when we were bringing in this
oxygen system we didn't want to bring in
something that was annoying to plays in
the resource tumors room you want
bringing something that could give them
cool new abilities so you can see we're
on the moon you can already do low
gravity jumps but we jump and then press
jump again you'll actually vent some
oxygen and you'll do a boo still allow
you go a little bit higher you can also
kind of push yourself forward so why
don't we do a jump and then boost
forward and one of the other cool things
you can do it's it's kind of my favorite
thing to do in the game in the mode it's
it's it's technically it's called a slam
but I like to call it but stomp if you
jump up in the air press jump again to
boost and then press crouched you
actually slam down to the ground into an
area of effect attack it's a great way
to manage Crouch to shove them back
because if in a low gravity area you can
push them back pretty far which might be
the edge that you need to either I run
away or focus on one guy before you deal
with the rest of the crowd all right now
we're gonna go ahead move into the next
area this is the comm facility there's a
signal that's being jammed that you need
to take care of so that you can get back
up to Helius which is the moonshot
facility and the pre-sequel jack is as
in charge of the Helios he's not the
Hyperion CEO yet that you know from
Borderlands 2 right now he's just
managing the station and you've been
kicked off and you got to get back
interesting up here kiddo you probably
would have had a bit of an Australian
accent there during the development of
the game it just so happened that the
moon kind of turned into Australia
alright now where we are right now
there's this big gap you wouldn't be
able to make this jump normally in
Borderlands by with the oxygen system we
can kind of push out this jump so let's
go ahead and see if we can clear that
gap
alright Athena you're up get plenty of
o2 so you can make this jump this is my
favorite part of the demo because I like
to push our demo drivers to boost as
late as possible oh just like that I
like to see them sweat so what do we
keep moving you'll notice when we boost
that oxygen meter is draining and you
can see in the horizon there there's
actually a beam show you up to the sky
and a HUD marker and that's an oxygen
generator we can activate that in a sec
but this is bottling so you know you
always loot and yeah low gravity no
atmosphere but when you actually
activate the oxygen generator now there
is atmosphere so when we open up this
other lootable you'll see that it
behaves differently we want to make sure
that the that this whole system felt
organic that it felt real they just feel
like it was tacked on this comes in
really important because with things
like incendiary if you set someone on
fire instead of a building with
atmosphere they'll burn but if you set
them on fire in the area no atmosphere
they won't so you kind of have to make
some you have some interesting
opportunities these guys up here I'm
sure they're up to no good so let's
throw some grenades at them
so in low gravity you get blown up by
grenade you go flying into all of it
very awesome now you'll see these guys
who are outside of the oxygen dome
they're wearing the same bubble that
you're in if you manage to get a head
shot like that they'll actually start
venting oxygen and become vulnerable and
this really brings tactics into play for
the players so you can come into a space
and if you have a really kick-ass
incendiary weapon you can choose to turn
on the oxygen or you can try and take
out their bubbles that way but why don't
we take it take a chance to have a look
at our our co-op buddy Wilhelm so people
probably remember will home from
Borderlands 2 is the big robot that you
fought right the being the first big
boss in this game he starts out just as
a man because this is his origin story
as well as many other characters and the
really cool thing is as you're building
out his skill tree not only do you gain
new abilities but you actually visually
change him as well you get robotic arms
robotic legs shoulder-mounted rocket
turrets you're essentially building out
his skill tree to tell the story of how
he became the boss he fought in
Borderlands 2 which we've had a lot of
fun making but I think it's probably
time to show off our first new action
skill for Borderlands the pre-sequel or
you think james yeah it sounds like a
good idea we're coming up on the barrier
here for the for the compa sylheti this
is being run by the scavs which are the
scavengers they're essentially moonbin
they're not gonna let us then without a
fight they're even bringing out some
heavy hitters to turrets but luckily
we've got our our aspis to help us with
that let's try to absorb as much damage
as we can and throw it back at them
so you can see that the shield is slowly
spinning up as it takes more and more
damage it's gonna spin faster and faster
you can kinda see it on the outer edge
which means that we're just about ready
to throw that fat awesome let's go and
take care of this other laser and then
get inside now because we never get
tired of blowing people off the side of
the Moon let's throw some more grenades
we like to do these demos live but
because this is a co-op game we can
always rely on our buddies that's right
always better to play with friends
alright now let's go ahead and show off
the the cryo gun we showed a little bit
earlier but didn't really get to see it
in action let's go and free some enemies
so we've actually built this procedural
system so you can freeze any enemy like
that and once you get the health down to
a sudden threshold you can shatter them
it's not an instant win button because
you do need to get their health download
but when you manage to do it it's really
satisfying and it's different every
single time we're gonna go and divide
and conquer so we can wipe out these
scabs a little bit faster and then we're
gonna try to meet back up in the wall
Peck I think that freezes guy and
trailer and press stomp them
the Athena had a good tactic that if
you've managed to get really high your
butt stuff will actually do more damage
so if you free someone you can but
something down and shut it and throw a
bow now you can do more than just
freezing them while they're on the
ground we've got some jet fighter some
sort of jet pack enemies let's try to
freeze them while they're in the air
so if we do manage to freeze one of
these guys in the air and they fall down
a railing they'll actually split in half
it's one of these kind of random events
that I love seeing the game this is also
a new enemy the badass outlaw now these
guys pretty big and because of the low
gravity if he charges in two you can
actually knock you pretty far but when
you shatter into a million pieces that
doesn't really matter too much it's very
satisfying now we did get a new skill
point while we were out there so let's
go ahead and allocate that we're gonna
put it into the the ultimate skill in
this tree that which has wrath of a
goddess this will allow Athena's shield
to bounce around multiple enemies inside
of a sort of like a closed circle
there's a great way to manage crowds Oh
Wilhelm looks like he got something what
is that so that's the doll laser that's
kind of like a boat laser Athena you
picked up the Molly one beam laser
before and as James said earlier you
have multiple manufacturers you have the
procedural weapons system so players can
expect to see a whole variety of
different types of lasers when they play
the game to the right here you'll see
one of the new rideable vehicles in
Borderlands the pre-sequel the stingray
we're not going to need in this mission
so we're gonna keep moving forward but
keep an eye out because we might have
something more about that and some later
news
all right I found the loot chest is pop
this open stably we have let's see if we
have a new kit over to the right here so
what is this Sasuke - let's see so it
looks like it increases your oxygen
meter it allows you to create an oxygen
bubble which comes in really handy when
doing a slam so let's go and give that
to Wilhelm and see we can if we can do
some damage with it
so the I feel EOS is charging up now and
it's actually firing into the surface of
the Moon which is probably not such a
good thing when you see bits of the
ground kind of floating above you like
that probably a good reason for us to
get back up to that Space Station as
soon as possible all right so we've got
a group of enemies coming up and so
we're gonna use our buddy Wilhelm to
help us charge up our shield so they can
get it going because you can use
friendly fire to charge up Athena shield
let's try and take out all those guys at
once all right awesome
all right well yeah but sometime
and you see that bubble you can write a
sign that note to recharge your oxygen
as we mentioned earlier you can also use
the option to set enemies on fire when
you're out in this sort of area so maybe
we go to Trinity does that maybe we go
yeah it is a really good combo if you
get that oxygen bubble with the fire to
burn enemies but I really love getting
the cryo one as well so you jump down
from high enough but stumped and [ __ ]
adder and fries go all in one go when we
try and get some little butt stumps
happening I never get tired of it
so we've got some little scabs a little
outlaw here this is a really good
opportunity to try and charge that
shield right up so absorb some more
damage it's fully spin now so just move
back a little bit Athena and fire it off
awesome
nice now there's a lot more resistance
in this area than we than we planned we
might need a little more help on this
one
who can help us out possibly
uh-oh all right we really need sound and
some help and we have label claptrap for
the first time ever in a bottle ends
game you get to play as claptrap and
he's gonna help us out a little bit in
this fight thanks buddy
let's fight these guys out and the other
playable character in bolas sequels
Misha the Walgreen who fans of the
franchise will also remember we were
talking about her in the light of day
beautiful frozen badass outlaw
so yeah we should probably head in here
and try and disable that signal sieve
and get up to the space station
all right you better get him Athena
getting close did we mention low gravity
already awesome well hey thanks everyone
for staying tuned performance of pre
sequel coming to you this fall
that's spring for all those ease out
there began